[Musica]
vi chiederete che cosa ci faccio una
speaker con un gomitolo in mano a
parlare di blockchain violenza e Donne
questo ve lo spiegherò tra poco
vedete
abbiamo un problema
sapete quante donne al mondo sono state
vittime di violenza
il 16% il 10% O il 27%, non siete timidi
rispondete
il 27%
. il che significa che sulle 3,64
miliardi di donne al mondo una su tre
è stata vittima di violenza
Quindi circa un miliardo
e sapete Quante in Italia
il 5 per cento la percentuale
16 16 per cento
il che significa che sulle 31 milioni di
donne in Italia 5 milioni sono state
vittime di violenza
questi dati li ho presi dalla WWE Show
Generation che ha preso esattamente
questo range dai 15 ai 49 anni quindi
tutto quello che al di fuori dai 15 ai
49 anni
non c'è in questi numeri
non solo questi sono i numeri delle
persone che
hanno Sport denuncia
vedete Io dovrei essere tra questi
numeri
ma non ho Sport denuncia quindi non ci
sono
ci sono tante forme di violenza c'è la
violenza verbale la violenza fisica la
violenza sessuale la violenza
psicologica
quest'ultima è un po' più difficile da
provare perché si pensa che sia tutto
nella propria testa
si pensa che magari non sta succedendo
quello che sta veramente succedendo
e quindi ci si chiede che cos'è
che non porta le donne a sporgere
denuncia
questi tre fattori
paura vergogna e mancanza di prove
per me era la paura la paura che
qualcos'altro accadesse Perché quando si
all'interno di un meccanismo di violenza
psicologica tu non sai esattamente dove
sia quella linea sottile che porti a
quel passo in più
poi ovviamente la vergogna perché
è difficile pensare dove era anche
affrontare le autorità o affrontare
quello che ti sta accadendo ed assai la
mancanza di prove
vedete
servirebbe qualcosa
che aiuti queste donne a superare questi
tre fattori
ed è qua che entra in gioco la
blockchain
riprendo il mio gomitolo
quindi mi faccio fare un gioco
adesso io vi lancio questo gomitolo
e chiedo per favore di lanciarlo tra il
pubblico dovete lanciarvelo uno ad uno
tendendo il filo però non lasciate mai
andare quel filo quel filo è quello che
dovete realmente avere in mano e tenere
sempre in mano Mi raccomando potete
lanciarlo anche da una parte all'altra
del pubblico in maniera tale che tutti
abbiano qualcosa da reggere e lanciatelo
proprio fate proprio il lancio non
abbiate paura dovete fermare una rete
Quella che è una rete che potrebbe anche
essere
quel tipo come un ragno
Ecco più o meno esatto questo questo
lancio è andato prendetelo pure anche se
è caduto
e poi dopo continuate a passarlo
vedete la blockchain è una tecnologia di
memoria
è un registro distribuito con tre
caratteristiche principali
l'immutabilità la sicurezza e la
trasparenza Potete smettere di lanciare
il gomitolo tranquilli Avete finito
e sono proprio queste tre
caratteristiche
che fanno sì che questa tecnologia sia
così innovativa ed è composta da nodi
nodi che sono processori sono dei
computer sparsi in giro per il mondo un
po' come Voi adesso siete sparse nel
pubblico e questi nodi contengono delle
informazioni esattamente come voi avete
le vostre informazioni avete la vostra
storia quello che vi è accaduto
e le condivideteli potete condividere
anche con persone che sono qui
i nodi della blockchain però condividono
le stesse informazioni in maniera tale
che non vengano perse che non vengano
eliminate che non vengano cancellate
proprio
e è per questo che già adesso ci sono
delle applicazioni che permettono a chi
è stata vittima di violenza di accedere
alla blockchain di accedere con questa
applicazione
mantenendo l'anonimato affrontando
quindi la paura che qualcos'altro accada
la vergogna di dover affrontare le
autorità
e la mancanza di prove è proprio la
blockchain che non permette che queste
prove vengano cancellate
rimangono lì e ci sono quindi non ci
sono anche Raggi non ci sono messaggi
persi cancellati chiamate che sono
andate perdute o oppure magari lividi
che sono andati via
questo non c'è
la blockchain quindi funge da amica così
come voi aiuteresti un'amica un amico in
difficoltà No è un testimone
e addirittura aiuta a superare anche il
fatto che circa metà delle denunce
prevalenza in certi paesi vengano
smarrite
perché è scritta a mano
perché messo in mezzo alle carte e perse
tra altre carte perché faxate il fax è
spento
quindi la blockchain non aiuta un
testimone non è solo una tecnologia
vi chiedo di fare un altro gioco quel
filo tendetelo
tenetelo forte tenetelo fortissimo tanto
che sentite proprio il muscolo che
brucia che sentite proprio la tensione
sentite quella connessione
ora rilasciate un pochino
Mi manca quella connessione
Questa è la forza che c'è di connessione
tra nodi della blockchain
e ora girate la testa guardando le
persone alla vostra destra
e poi le persone alla vostra sinistra
una donna su tre Qui è stata vittima di
violenza
Perciò vi dico adesso abbiamo un alleato
abbiamo un amico abbiamo la blockchain
che ci può aiutare non può cancellare il
fenomeno questo no ma può combatterlo
può aiutare Quindi usiamo questa
tecnologia per far sì che quel 27%
diventi un 10%. e quel 16% diventi un 5
per cento
così come vi avevo detto che è un'amica
è un aiuto
sia per uomini che per donne
quindi in questo caso utilizziamola
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]